Now, for a bit of advice on assertions. First of all, assertions take time.
If for every single operation on a large data structure, you're to traverse the anti-tree
in order to check it for consistency,
these operations will be no longer logarithmic time but at least linear time.
A check on a square root result will not matter that much,
but if you need to traverse large data structures, it will.
This is why assertions can be turned off.
The way assertions are being turned on and off differs from the language used.
In Python, there is a -O option which turns assertions off. -O stands for optimized.
In C/C++, the compiler option -DNDEBUG for no debugging also turns assertions off.
In Java, there is an option -ea for enable assertions which turns assertions on.
Java special by having assertions turned off by default.
Not very surprisingly, the assert keyword in Java is the least frequently used
of all keywords in Java, which in my view is a big, big shame.
The fact that assertions can be turned off and frequently will also implies that
that assertions must not change the program semantics.
Whether assertions are turned on or turned off, the behavior of the program should be the same.
Suppose you're developing this cool map application,
which also supports setting pins for individual locations.
Now, you want to make sure that if you remove a location,
the appropriate function returns the right value so just remove it.
And if you're right, assert map.remove location equals to True,
in order to make sure that remove location returns the true value that's dangerous
because if the assertion is turned off here, then not only does the check go away
but actually also the call to remove.
Generally speaking, if anything in your assertion has side effects such as this one,
don't put it into the assertion.
What you do instead is you put the functionality into code that is outside of the assertion
and then use the assertion only for checking the result.
This way if the assertion is turned off has no effect
then the semantics of the program will still be unchanged except that the checks will be gone.